as you walk down the halls of the scp foundation
site 19 speaking in the various windows at the
anomalies contained there you might catch a
glimpse of a dark figure bent over a table
tinkering away like an artisan in his workshop
a vintage black apothecary bag sits next to him
open and if you stop and watch for a while
you'll see him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that shouldn't fit
in such a small bag a bone saw an iv stand jars of
fluorescent liquids and needles the length
of your forearm you shouldn't be surprised
this is a place for impossible things after all
still it's a curious sight the shadowy man working
so diligently so quietly focused singularly on his
craft whatever that might be only one thing could
distract him from his efforts you he feels your
gaze on him and he looks up dark eyes glittering
from behind a beaked ceramic mask he reminds you
of an illustration you once saw in a book about
the black death the gear the plague doctors wore
while treating patients on their deathbeds hello
he greets you in a friendly heavily accented voice
his eyes crinkle beneath the mask and if you could
see his mouth you know he'd be smiling how are
you today dear fellow are you feeling quite well
he takes a step toward the window stretching out
one gloved hand and you suddenly realize that you
can't see where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face this is no
ordinary man do you require help i can examine
you he offers palm press flat against the glass
a chill runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on his offer
no matter how friendly he seems how good his
intentions may be you wouldn't want to let the
plague doctor treat you he sat in his containment
cell fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work table back
and forth listening to the sound it made they had
tried to confiscate his table his tools the guards
had quickly learned that he had more of them
in his bag they tried to take away his bag from
him but well that didn't go over too well for
anyone involved so he was allowed to keep it to
fashion himself a makeshift laboratory in his
lonely little cell there was a time where they
had given him test subjects fresh corpses from
the morgue for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would come to
speak with him talking of cryptobiology and the
pestilence he had dedicated himself to fighting
those days were long gone he had hidden away
pieces of the corpses tissue samples and jars of
formaldehyde he could pull out when the monotony
became too much but the days of fresh materials of
enlightened discourse with other men and women
of science were over how he missed those days
the chance to work with others as he once had what
had he done wrong all he did was treat the sick
sure they didn't always understand their illness
didn't want to receive their medicine but
that wasn't a choice for the patient to make
that should have been up to the physician
perhaps they didn't trust his expertise didn't see
how his work served the greater good like those
who watched jonas salk invent the polio vaccine
or louis pasteur rid milk of bacteria they were
confused by the advanced scientific practices
and feared that which they did not understand
he could forgive them for their ignorance he
was magnanimous that way if only they would
let him out of this infernal room he could prove
his work's worth to them he could cure them all
begin a new era of wellness and peace worldwide
he didn't exactly sleep but when he rested on his
little cot in the corner of the room he dreamed of
that future of a world healed by his touch a knock
at the door stirred him from his reverie someone
someone was at the door of his containment cell
he glanced at the little window and saw a guard
there with a tray of food he greeted the man with
an enthusiastic wave sustenance he didn't require
the food for survival of course but it helped his
mind work more efficiently it reminded him of a
time before these fluorescent lights and these
same four walls of crusty bread with fresh butter
by the banks of the sin the little slot opened
in the door and the tray was shoved through there
was bread just as he hoped a small dish of butter
pot of jam and a cup of tea still seeming he
picked up the cup at first taking a deep breath
ah an herbal blend with fresh lavender lovely he
couldn't see the guard through the window anymore
but he called out to him just the same thank you
for the libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he could have
gotten a better look at the man seen the power of
his complexion a tremor in his hand he thought he
had spotted sweat beating on his forehead could he
be ill the case required further examination to be
certain he sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just let him work
why must they scream at the sight of his efforts
flee from his instruments it didn't seem
fair still the pursuit of science rarely was
a glamorous one he had learned as much over the
centuries one day though history would look back
on him kindly of this he could be certain he was
just settling in and beginning to spread butter
across the admittedly stale bread when a horrible
sound shook him to attention he had heard the
noise before though he had never seen its source
it was an ear splitting scream a whale of pure
agony like the sound of a wounded wild animal he
had heard many many screams during his life from
patients and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into custody of
the foundation he had never heard a scream quite
like this one it was pure rage devastation and
suffering mixed together wet with tears and
loud enough to rip through human vocal folds
whatever was crying out it was no mere man more
screams answered it and these were very much human
these sounds were more familiar to him shrieks
of pain a fear of desperate but futile attempts
to escape then the meaty thud of bodies falling
to the floor of torn off limbs hitting walls and
windows a loud crash and the sound of something
large moving quite quickly through the halls
scientific curiosity got the better of the doctor
and he found himself moving back to his little
window face pressed to the glass so hard his beak
nearly cracked it he couldn't see much of anything
just guards running down the hall weapons drawn
he saw one of them fire heard the gunshot ring
out but what was he firing at then he
saw it a pale blur darting past the door
whatever it was it didn't so much as flinch
when the bullet ricocheted off its skin
a long thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his work table
he steadied himself and climbed back to his
feet taking in the damage done to the door
it was crumpled in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it was already
gone from the sounds of chaos in the distance it
had disappeared around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of the door
to his containment cell it was useless now hanging
loose and open well that was an invitation he was
hardly about to decline he grabbed his trusty bag
tossed his scalpel back inside and set off to see
what all the commotion was it was easy enough to
follow the trail of blood stark and vivid red
against the white tile floor and the sound of
gunfire human screams and that loud long painful
whale he had heard before he walked at a leisurely
pace taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found a mound of
bodies guards and scientists beaten and bloodied
almost beyond recognition it was quiet here
save for one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to the wall
was a pale thin figure its shoulders heaving
with the force of its sobs this poor soul was
clearly in great distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white extended arms wrapped around
itself as it cried excuse me the doctor cried
out to the pitiful creature are you alright
do you need assistance it didn't answer it just
continued to cry had something so despondent been
responsible for this destruction the dozens of
corpses the smashed in walls the crumbled doors
and shattered windows it seemed impossible sure
it was large and looked strong but he had never
seen a monster cry before this couldn't be
a dangerous creature not when it was so sad
he would help it but first he would attend
to some of these bodies he sat his bag on
the ground and pulled out several vials of liquid
a set of syringes and a variety of other surgical
tools he might need now after such a long hiatus
he could resume his work in a meaningful way he
couldn't be certain how long he worked reviving
these poor souls and reconstructing their bodies
as the pale creature wept in the corner the
sobbing faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he removed a
liver here placed it in a chest cavity there poked
and prodded injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures one by one
the milky eyes fluttered open rigor mortis stiff
joints creaked into motion sallow faces looking at
his with the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need to thank
him with their words the work was its own reward
he expected more guards to arrive to attempt to
contain the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose creature
he didn't seem to notice his presence at all
not even when he had brought all of the intact
corpses back to life the patient shuffled around
the room aimlessly waiting for orders of some kind
the doctor tapped one on the shoulder and handed
the reborn man a vial of thick black medicine give
this to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him provide
some relief from his suffering the corpse nodded
mouth hanging loose and open an eyeball dangling
unseen from the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial to it
it turned lifting its head and as it locked eyes
with the cured patient something shifted in its
face its mouth opened wide impossibly wide and
a treat that same terrible sound as before tears
streamed from its colorless eyes its arms shaking
with unbridled rage has its jaws locked around
the patient's head like a boa constrictor in one
fluid motion it swallowed the revived man whole
while the doctor watched in shock he had been
wrong this was not an innocent creature caught
in the wrong place at the wrong time this creature
whatever it was was deeply sick he had never seen
such an advanced aggressive case of the pestilence
he'd heard rumors of course but never encountered
it firsthand as a doctor he had sworn to do no
harm but in a drastic situation drastic measures
have to be taken it was well known by himself and
the doctors at this foundation that he could cause
any and all biological functions in an organism
to cease with a single touch and so he approached
the creature arm outstretched ready to administer
that necessary touch to protect the rest of his
patients as he approached the creature turned to
him its eyes wide and blank an endless stream of
tears pouring from them spilling onto the floor
it shrieked again mouth stretching wide enough
to engulf his entire head and ran toward him at
a breakneck speed i am so sorry you are not well
the doctor said simply as his hand pressed
to the creature's chest as soon as the tough
hide of the doctor's hand which the uninformed
might mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the beast its eyes closed its
muscles went slack and it collapsed to the ground
with a mighty thigh the doctor paced around
the fallen creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the creature's
chest still rose and fell was it his imagination
he checked its pulse and thought it was
slow and faint and though was slow and faint
it was very much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered unconscious by
his touch rather than completely deceased curious
very curious indeed he muttered perhaps there were
comorbidities present other infections aside
from the pestilence which rendered the creature
unnaturally strong resilient to the usual courses
of treatment what would cause these abilities this
intense aggression it seemed to be brought on
whenever someone looked at the entity's face
if only he studied psychology more the science
of the mind and its inner workings since he had
no experience with therapy nor was he certain this
creature could communicate using language at all
there was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he would have
to take it apart and see for himself it was slow
work getting the massive creature back to the
doctor's containment cell he required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its massive
limbs and dragged the limp body through the halls
once back in a familiar environment his work
table ready and waiting the doctor instructed his
assistants to place the new patient on the table
it was a bit small unable to accommodate the
creature's distended limbs but if he attempted
to use an official foundation laboratory he
risked discovery and subsequent interruption
so it would have to suffice first he set up an
iv stand filled with a vivid green liquid it
was easy to find a vein the creature's skin was
nearly translucent now that he could be certain
the creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
he held out a hand and his favorite surgical blade
was placed in it by one of the helpful patients
thank you he slid the scalpel along the hairline
of the creature or where the hairline would be
if it weren't completely bald once the scalp was
removed he set it aside for later when it could be
reattached bonsa please he held out his hand again
and again his assistant gave him the proper tool
this however was when things got strange the
doctor had always been a deft hand at cutting he'd
once even received tutelage from the great robert
liston but no matter how hard he tried to saw it
never left a scratch on the creature's skeleton
naturally this was somewhat frustrating he wanted
to study the creature's brain tissue to get a
sense for what was going up there neurologically
and he couldn't do that if it was impossible to
saw off the creature's cranial cap he blunted two
of his favorite saws while trying thankfully there
was still a solution to access the beast's gray
matter a little trick he learned while studying
the funerary practices of the ancient egyptians
he produced a long curved hook from his bag
and inserted it up the creature's nasal passage
with some fine maneuvering he eventually managed
to remove the brain it was such a terrible shame
that he needed to do it piece by piece via the
nasal passage but one makes do all that was
left was to sew the skin of the creature's head
back into place it was mid-stitch when a voice
interrupted his careful work nearly making him
drop the needle hey what are you doing he looked
up to find a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me i am in surgery at the moment please do not
interrupt he admonished the guard but the man did
not listen or lower his weapon in fact he shouted
something into the radio code words the doctor
didn't recognize then he fired a bullet into the
skull of the patient standing at his side how dare
you the doctor cried readying himself to confront
the guard but it was too late dozens of other
guards were swarming the room and neutralizing
his assistance some in hazmat suits grabbed his
arms and pulled him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he fought or
how loudly he protested then something incredible
happened something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one another's
faces the guard tensed preparing for the worst but
nothing came the creature simply stared placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing and flesh no mouth
opening wider and wider to swallow the manhole i
did it the doctor shouted overcome with elation
i've cured you now begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the shockingly
calm creature away back to its containment cell
the doctor's door was repaired and he was returned
to his state of captivity but he never forgot the
patient he helped that day and how marvelous it
felt to do such a good deed meanwhile scp-096's
brain regrew within the hour and caused another
massive containment breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards but the staff agreed not to
tell scp-049 about any of this better to just let
him have this one he really seemed like he needed
a win now go check out scp-049 the plague doctor
everything you need to know and scp-096 shy guy
escape incident 096-1-a containment breach for
more videos on today's terrifying combatants